los residentes de este barrio de kiev
tuvieron un duro despertar ventanas
rotas vehículos destruidos junto a los
edificios
los bomberos no escatimaron esfuerzos
durante la noche una impresionante
lluvia de misiles rusos y drones
kamikaces golpeó la capital ucraniana
los residentes están en estado de shock
oí una explosión muy fuerte rápidamente
saltamos de la cama y vimos un coche en
llamas luego los demás coches también se
incendiaron
es difícil explicar lo que siento un
metro a la izquierda o a la derecha y
podría haber sido mi apartamento no
tengo palabras
estos bombardeos rusos los mayores desde
hace seis semanas han matado a varias
personas diez regiones ucranianas han
sido golpeadas entre ellas lip en el
oeste que no había sido golpeada hasta
ahora ni Pro nikolaíff o saporilla donde
la mayor central nuclear del país quedó
desconectada de la red nacional
numerosas instalaciones energéticas
también han sido atacadas en toda
Ucrania dejando a millones de hogares
sin electricidad la novedad de estos
ataques calificados de tácticas
miserableski es el uso por parte de
Rusia de al menos seis misiles
hipersónicos kinghal un arma que kiev no
tiene forma de derribar porque el
kinghal vuela al menos dos veces más
rápido que los misiles dedicados a su
defensa antiaérea según los expertos
Moscú dispone de varias decenas de estos
misiles hipersónicos